la Zoe fait ses premiers tours de roues
sur le bitum la nouvelle voiture
électrique de Renault et tivelinoise
conçue au technoocentre de gu en cour
est produite à Flin elle vient d'être
lancée sur le marché premier à tout son
prix 13700 € grâce au bonus écologique
de 7000 € l'équivalent de la cliod
diesel autre nouveauté une autonomie
plus importante 210 km homologué soit
150 km d'autonomie réelle et pour cela
Renault a intégré des innovations
technologiques une pompe à chaleur pour
faire la climatisation ou le chauffage
ce qui va permettre de consommer trois
fois moins qu'un système conventionnel
des pneus Michelin énergie vie à faible
frottement dont Zoe à l'exclusivité et
enfin un système de récupération
d'énergie au freinage de toute nouvelle
génération autre point noir souvent
évoqué la recharge la Zoe a intégrer un
chargeur embarqué caméléon qui s'adapte
automatiquement à la puissance de la
borne de recharge compté de 30 minutes à
9h pour une charge complète un câble est
fourni pour se brancher sur les bornes
publiques ou sur la wallbox à installer
chez soi pas de problème de vol pour le
retirer il faut avoir la clé malgré ses
efforts cette CIN places avec boîte
automatique assez réactive avec ses 88
chevaux n'en reste pas moins une
citadine c'est une voiture qui sera
vraiment agréable à conduire tout au
long de la semaine et qui vous permettra
également de faire des économies puisque
passer 10000 km par an euh ça va revenir
beaucoup moins cher de rouler un
électrique 10000 km pour rentabiliser le
coût de la location de la batterie 79 €
par mois un seuil qui pourrait se
réduire si le prix à la pompe augmente
au-delà de l'aspect technique la Zoé
plaît aussi pour son design à
l'intérieur un tableau de bord qui
évoque une palle d'éolienne un volant
modulable et surtout un tableau tactile
qui propose navigation par GPS
disponibilité des bornes de recharge et
une multitude d'applications comme
Coyote des flux d'information ou l'accès
aux réseaux sociaux et pour le model zen
un diffuseur de centeur peut être
l'astuce pour respecter la semaine de la
courtoisie au
volant